heures pas de longs week-ends en
revanche pour les nouveaux membres du
gouvernement
hier soir la plus jeune de l'équipe a
fait sa première sortie sur le terrain
en tant que ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche valérie
pécresse 39 ans à la charge de mettre en
oeuvre la réforme de l'université et les
nuques à la location et là encore désert
d'étudiante et pourtant c'est elle la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
valérie pécresse à tu et à toi hier soir
avec le directeur général de la cité des
sciences publiera aujourd'hui une
première visite de terrain très
symbolique réflexion on a une crise des
vocations scientifiques
on a perdu notamment en licences on a
perdu 30 mille élèves depuis 98 il faut
absolument qu'on les récupère redonner
goût à la science premier défi pour
valérie pécresse notamment par
l'expérimentation deuxième défi former
des chercheurs nombreux et surtout
enrayer la fuite des cerveaux
l'attractivité d'autres métiers les
métiers du secteur privé est trop fort
par rapport au métier aux métiers de
l'enseignement et la recherche
donc il va falloir essayer de trouver
des moyens y compris financiers premier
signe en direction du monde de la
recherche en crise depuis plusieurs
années mais pas un mot sur les
universités
le gros chantier qui attend la nouvelle
ministre